the cord was in for phip rubow is their backup
net minder played here from ma with a shot just
wide in the rebound oh it's in on De Court he
stopped it trying to lift it oh did it go in
Baleno at the post are you serious yeah Baleno
with the wide open net Comer over back to the
line gos is fa in didn't stay in though as Jaden
chok toward will carry ahead back here to bork
strand in on goal tip big sa oh and over top of
the net there on a second one from wiber points
last few years Michigan's had a Powerhouse a lot
of guys went high in the draft and are playing
well in the NHL right now into the middle good
save made off Barren on the wing back in here
for Schwarz waits for help coming back to
disrupt with rash Houston monic goes for
tolven in nice waiver pick up for Seattle last
season right on the doorstep and held though
by who hit for Ellie tolven who led all players
came claimed off waivers and points last season
came from Nashville stolen there and away is
Dylan Lin he's in the clear save made by Joey
dord right there he makes the the play himself
hooked it right off the Seattle player and he
missed his shot Dy Lin you see this thing
he wanted to go higher and he didn't get
it pop between pper and Ras
mus strong let go set up neatly by
go [Applause] despar back for Daniel
strong for oie mat scores K in Fr for no
it's one nothing well there's a makeup for
the crossbar not quite start a period but
first two minutes minute 7 seconds in and
there's no chance for the goal tender
here Daniel strong look at the flex in
that stick on The Mod shot redirected by
B it was too close to the crossbar for Joe
again oh able to knock it down and took a knock
to the boards from sh fer able to come up with
her be open his turn a penalty coming at the
same time it depends on where the referee was
when he when he saw it happen it looked bad it
may not have been bad well that came right in
front of the goal and they score wow Schwarz
went to the net and it bobbled through whoo
on their first try did this ever take a funny
bounce good job by Seattle to muscle that puck
off the boards back to the point and the
backhander hits Uso bounces up took forever
and just landed just inside the goal line just a
weird one went off the side of the net seeo had
trouble recovering from that and he had no idea
where it went after that it hit him and we got
a tie game just like that seconds into the for
played it for borgan no icing this way either
cider back Everly first on to Jake wman to the
middle gave it away though Everly right in on
goal and a save made BYO who bails out wman on
that one here's another incomer drops it back
for cup save made upop with another shot cider
in the rebound stop wenberg ahead Schwarz is in
scores got a couple boy oh boy chance at one end
right down the other end there and away they go
nice lead pass to Schwarz and he rips it looked
like Uso got a piece of it over the pad on the
glove yeah maybe a hair on the bottom of that
catching glove and Seattle's got the lead 65
seconds to go in the second gos of spares got
it and had it knocked down lead pass there and
in the Clear Car scores oh the fans are going
to be angry at this one as Tai K in his sixth
game gets his second goal sprung into the clear
for the AHL Rookie of the Year from Coachella
Valley PR not see that he's looking right at it
I mean and that was schw but not enough well the
Red Wings have three comeback wins already this
season all one goal scar wow quick shot back
of the net gos despair was that a rocket in the
short side top corner and right off the [Music]
draw did gos bear scramble to get in position and
that that shot had to be perfect cider faked the
shot right there for a moment then fed it off and
that little split second a he can talk about this
if he gets a chance later on that Split Second
where cider might shoot that he has to stay in
position and then the pass is made he's a hair
late been stun pretty smart play right there away
from traffic here comes Jed mccan in on goal and
a save by hoso down it goes for Pon stick check
dos is fa to get it for another chevet Lin in
front of theor there's gos to spare they take
the shot away does Lexia down to lens what a
shot top Corner whoa Dylan lens got the team
leid for four power play gsus bear to Larin top
shelf fourth goal third on the power play and 13
points this season a point every game that is a
perfect shot and Larin has been practicing that
for a year and a half top Corner top Corner HCK
came up high on the Dasher knock down and gos
is be to dig it free to Larin now to Pon back
to cider to gois Bear top of the right Circle
down low Lin finds the break it [Applause] scar
it's four to three three for six on the power
play on the left side can do you get an open
side to the left of a goal tender where does
this one go exactly on that side the catching
glove side he caught the golender moving
and you see that he's moving from left to
right and to Brick it goes fans wanted to
call veneers comper working it Far Side 90
seconds to go in the third a bump there by
cider Puck loose for veneers Schwarz heads
to the front of the net he's got two goals
tonight back for Jared mccan a shot he scores
oh he's t TI It Up season a 40 goal man last
season well you almost had some contact
there in front of the net with with whoo
I don't know if Schwarz it went up the
cour of gone to the bench as well they
win the draw here Everly's got it into
the slot big save there great chance he
just tried to go through the big guy's
legs screen the shot and hit him alexc
blocked it we're going overtime wouldn't you
know at 5-1 on an 823 puck drop a wild third
[Applause] period there it goes right to
where he placed gos Fair too Winnipeg will
be in here on Thursday normal start time
tier to the corner for Raymond 22 seconds
left Raymond right in Firing Line hit the
out post look out air break the other way
done the defenseman with Everly hustling
back as Comer Everly's got it fires that
one went wide here's mccan with room pass
to FR they score Everly from McAn with 5
seconds left in overtime 455 Seattle wins it
to break the Red Wings five game winning streak